.
* Beunruhigende Klänge *
Mireya
steht vor einer Lebertransplantation.
Schau, sie sind schon bereit.
Wir sind die Doktoren.
Wir geben diese Medikamente
durch die Vene.
Ein Eingriff,
der ihr Leben retten soll.
Wir machen langsam,
kein Problem.- So.
Ich glaube, sie ist schon weg.
Tschüss, Mireya, mach's gut.
Sie merkt nichts mehr. Tschau.
Mach's gut. Okay?
Alles gut bei dir?
* Melancholische Musik *
Sie sind krank
und wollen nichts als leben.
Sie warten auf ein Organ,
das ein Verstorbener spendet.
Ein Leben geht zu Ende,
eines wird verlängert.
Die Organtransplantation
ist ein Eingriff, der bewegt.
Es geht um Ethik,
Glaube, Gesetz und Moral.
Um grosses Glück ...
Man muss sehen, ich habe
ein Leben geschenkt bekommen.
... und um Ängste.
Was bedeutet die Transplantation
für die Empfänger/-innen?
Wie läuft sie ab?
Wir hatten den Schnitt
um ca. 8.20 Uhr.
Und die Leber ist sehr schön.
Es braucht wahnsinnig Geduld.
Wie ist die Lebensqualität
nach dem grossen Eingriff?
Es geht um Warten,
Hoffnung und vielleicht ...
... Erlösung.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Zeig mal, was in der Puppe drin ist.
Er hat hier
so einen Reissverschluss im Bauch.
Das sind Darm ...
... Herz, Lunge ...
... Leber.
Wo ist die Niere?
Hier, das ist die Niere.
Und das, die Leber?
- Leber.
Leber.
Das Leben der Familie Rast dreht sich
um die Krankheit der Tochter.
Wenn ein Kind stirbt,
kriege ich seine Leber.
Dann rufen sie uns an ...
Dann rufen sie uns an
und dann muss ich sofort nach Genf.
In Genf befindet sich
das Leberzentrum für Kinder.
Operiert werden.
Das einzige in der Schweiz.
Mireya leidet unter
einer extrem seltenen Genkrankheit.
Weltweit sind nur
ein paar wenige Fälle bekannt.
Zurzeit geht es ihr gut.
Sie besucht die Schule.
Was machst du ohne Rocco ...
- Ja.
Noch fünf, oder?
Oder 80?
Wie viel?
- 80. 85.
Ein für andere Kinder harmloser
Infekt aber, Husten oder Schnupfen,
kann für sie lebensgefährlich werden.
... gibt fünf.
Die Eltern sind in ständiger Sorge.
Das hat man immer im Kopf,
egal, was man macht.
Bei der Arbeit, beim Fernsehen,
wenn man irgendwo hingeht.
Das beschäftigt einen.
Und - wie soll ich sagen -
das bleibt auch drin.
Mhm.
- Das kann man nicht abschalten.
Auch nach der Transplantation ...
Kann man nicht abstellen.
- ... ist das Teil unseres Lebens.
Schon zweimal
erkrankte Mireya schwer.
Sie hatte hohes Fieber.
Die Leber versagte.
Beim ersten Mal
wurde Mireya in Bulgarien behandelt,
der Heimat der Mutter.
Beim zweiten Mal in der Schweiz.
Ich hatte überall Schläuche.
Hier sieht man es,
am Hals irgendwo.
In der Nase hatte ich einen,
im Mund, hier zwei, hier noch einen,
am Fuss eine Infusion,
hier neun Infusionen.
Einen Katheter auch.
Ich konnte gar nicht reden.
Das Essen bekam ich über Schläuche.
Mein Körper
hat gar nicht gearbeitet, nichts.
Das war nicht so gut.
Sie konnte nicht spielen.
* Sie machen Geräusche. *
Nein, tu es hierhin.
Bald wird Mireya
auf die sog. Dringlichkeitsliste
für die Lebertransplantation gesetzt.
Die Zeit drängt.
Zu gross ist die Gefahr, dass sie
jetzt, im Winter, wieder erkrankt.
Die Koffer sind gepackt.
Die müssen wir bereithaben,
für wenn das Telefon klingelt.
Dann müssen wir schnell gehen.
Ich möchte meine neue Leber haben.
Aua.
Tatsächlich: Schon nach wenigen Tagen
wird Mireya
zur Organtransplantation aufgeboten.
Gegen Mitternacht trifft sie
im Universitätsspital Genf ein.
* Nervöse Klänge *
Die Voruntersuchungen
werden Stunden dauern.
Die Operation
soll am nächsten Tag stattfinden.
Hast du Stress?
- Nein.
Hast du gehört?
Du wirst erst um 11 Uhr operiert.
Okay.
* Der Vater gähnt laut. *
Tut das weh?- Nein.
- Das?- Nein.
Es wird eine kurze Nacht
für Familie Rast.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Die Co-Leiterin des Leberzentrums,
Barbara Wildhaber, kommt zur Visite.
Schau, wer kommt. Hoher Besuch.
- Hoi, Mäuschen. Hoi.
Bist du auch gekommen?
Hoi.
Bist du durcheinander?- Mhm.
- Das verstehe ich.
Wie geht es dir, von 0-10?
- Gut. 10.
10 von 10? Schön gut.
Haben Sie das gehört?
10 von 10.
- Ja.
Du kommst bald in den OP,
dann geht das grosse Abenteuer los.
Du weisst, was das heisst, oder?
(Flüsternd)
Du hast etwas Angst, nicht?
Verstehe ich. Müssen wir ja
niemandem sagen.- Mhm.
Hast du noch eine Frage?- Nein.
- Perfekt, dann gehen wir.
Bekommen Sie gerade Herzklopfen?
Immer mehr, ja.
- Gehen Sie in den OP mit ihr.
Gehen Sie dann etwas trinken
und schlafen -
ich weiss, das werden Sie nicht,
aber tun Sie so.- Oder herumlaufen.
Mir steigen auch
Tränen in die Augen.
Die Eltern sind so geladen.
Nach allem, was die erlebt haben.
Sie haben ihre Tochter
schon zweimal praktisch verloren.
Jetzt geben sie sie ab
undwissen nicht, was passiert.
Ich weiss, es ist kontrolliert,
aber sie nicht.
Sie sind in Todesangst
um ihre Tochter,
weil sie von uns auch gehört haben,
dass es ein Riesending ist.
Darum konnte ich nicht mit. Sonst
wären mir auch die Tränen gekommen.
Alles gut bei dir?
* Traurige Klänge *
Puh.
Genf ist das einzige Transplan-
tationszentrum in der Schweiz,
das die Leber
bei Kindern transplantieren darf.
Routine ist dieser Eingriff aber nie.
Die Freude,
dass wir ein Organ für Mireya haben,
ist emotional angestrichen mit der
Trauer, dass jemand gestorben ist.
Die Transplantation
beginnt um 11 Uhr am Mittag.
Un petit peut, s'il te plaît.
Das ist das Schlimmste.
Du bist nur am Warten und Warten.
Hättest du geschlafen,
wäre es vielleicht anders.- Nein.
Für mich schon.
Hätte ich genug geschlafen,
wäre es ein bisschen anders.
Allein die Entnahme der kranken Leber
nimmt Stunden in Anspruch.
Non. Encore un peu.
Tu vois.
Wir sind sehr glücklich,
alles bestens bis jetzt.
Es sieht schön aus.
Wir haben richtig Freude.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Den Ärzten,
die sie bis jetzt behandelt haben,
können wir blindlings vertrauen.
Das soll auch so sein.
Du hast ja keine andere Wahl.
Du kannst ihnen nur vertrauen -
was willst du machen?
Ja, und wenn ...
(Ärztin) Was sitzen denn Sie hier?
- Wir warten.
Oh.- Alles bestens, alles bestens.
Wir machen nur eine Pause.
Jetzt hatte ich
eine halbe Herzattacke.
Nein, nein. Alles bestens.
- (Mutter) Ist alles gut?
Ja, ja!
Darum haben wir eine kleine Pause.
Wir haben gerade von Ihnen
gesprochen.- Entschuldigung.
Wir haben nicht mit Ihnen gerechnet.
Entschuldigung,
ich auch nicht mit Ihnen.
Wieso sind Sie da?- Weil sie
diese Zone nicht gerne verlässt.
Aber Sie dürfen doch.
Es geht immer noch ein paar Stunden.
Es geht bestens - so gut,
dass wir jetzt eine Pause haben.
Aha, okay.
Ich gehe etwas essen.
- Ja?
Also geht es nachher los?
- Die Leber ist noch drin.
Wir müssen auf die neue warten.
Wir haben 30 Min. Pause.
Es ging so gut,
dass wir schneller waren.
Von daher ... Entschuldigung,
Sie hatten fast eine Herzattacke.
* Spannungsvolle Musik *
Erst jetzt
trifft die Spenderleber ein.
Mireya und ihre Eltern
werden nie erfahren, woher sie kommt.
Der Spender bleibt anonym.
Für die Empfänger
könnte es belastend sein,
Details
zu den Todesumständen zu erfahren.
Nur so viel ist klar: Es handelt sich
um einen Teil einer Erwachsenenleber.
Achtung, die Leber rutscht.
Bon.
Il est beau.
Die Leber ist das einzige Organ,
das sich
auf zwei Empfänger aufteilen lässt.
Wunderschön. Wunderschöne Leber.
Das richtige Gewicht,
das wir uns vorgestellt haben.
Die Gefässe sind schön.
Wir sind im Moment glücklich.
Jetzt wird es langsam ...
zack, zack, zack.
Die Leber
kommt aus dem kalten Wasser
in den warmen Körper von Mireya.
Da müssen wir schnell machen,
da spreche ich
nicht mehr Schweizerdeutsch.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Voilà, voilà.
Je sais, j'ai compris.
Die kranke Leber
wird herausgeschnitten.
On rinse, s'il te plaît.
Wegen des seltenen Gendefekts
wird Mireyas Leber
genau untersucht werden,
hier in Genf, aber auch im Ausland.
Die Forscher erhoffen sich
Aufschlüsse über die Krankheit.
Jetzt geht es darum, die Spenderleber
mit Mireyas Gefässen zu verbinden.
Comme ça. Je pense qu'il faut faire
le milieu là en bas.
Derrière.
Vas-y, s'il te plaît.
Die grösste Anspannung
scheint vorbei.
Barbara Wildhaber
spricht wieder Schweizerdeutsch.
Das ist der grosse Moment
der Transplantation,
wenn das Blut
wiederdurch die Leber geht.
Sie ist im Moment bräunlich
und wird jetzt - hoffentlich -
wieder schön rosarot.
Okay, très bien. Schöne Leber.
Jetzt bekommt die gute Leber
noch die Arterie,
dann wird sie ganz zufrieden sein.
Kurz vor 19 Uhr,
8 Std. nach Beginn der Operation,
endlich die erlösende Botschaft.
Wir haben die Gefässe kontrolliert.
Alles fliesst gut.
Und die anderen Organe, alles gut?
- Ja, wir sind froh.
Danke.
Auf diese Nachricht
haben wir gewartet.
* Hoffnungsvolle Musik *
Hallo, Mireya.
Wenn du sie wieder so siehst ...
Das macht dich fertig, das Ganze.
Aber was willst du?
Sie muss durch,
dann müssen wir das auch.
Der nächste Morgen.
Oho!
Ist es normal, dass sie wach ist
und nachher wieder schläft?
Ja. Sie hat viele Medikamente
noch nicht ganz eliminiert.
Das braucht noch etwas Zeit.
Auch nach drei Jahren
ist die Operation für Familie Rast
eine schwere Erinnerung.
* Der Hund hechelt. *
Auf der einen Seite hast du Angst.
Es kann sein,
dass es nicht gut läuft.
Und ähm ...
Auf der anderen Seite ...
Du musst positiv denken.
Sonst nimmt dich die Situation
noch mehr mit.
Ich weiss nur eins:
Ich war gar nicht mich selbst.
Ich war dort ein anderer Mensch.
Alles auf ... Abwehrmodus.
Ich musste schauen, dass mich die
ganze Situation nicht kaputtmacht.
Wie es mir ging,
wollte ich nicht gross zeigen.
Ich bin einer,
der die Gefühle für sich behält.
Aber ich habe versucht,
sie zu unterstützen.
Gleichzeitig musste ich
mit meinem Kampf umgehen.
V.a. gute Spitäler, gute Ärzte usw.
Das ist Gold wert.
Wir waren gut aufgehoben.- Ein
grosses Dankeschön an den Arzt.
Luzern, Zürich, Genf.
- Ärztin.
Ärztin und Arzt.
Ja, das ganze Personal.
Die Reinigungsfrau, die Schwester -
alle.
Heute ist Ruhe eingekehrt.
* Gemütlich-verspielte Klänge *
Mireya wird in diesem Jahr zwölf.
Sie nimmt täglich Medikamente,
lebt sonst aber ohne Einschränkungen.
Dass sie mit einer fremden Leber
lebt, ist kein Thema mehr für sie.
Ich fühle mich
wie ein normales Kind, gesund.
Ich fühle mich nicht krank oder so.
Wenn ich Abwechslung habe,
denke ich nicht oft daran.
In der Schweiz tritt frühestens 2024
die Widerspruchslösung in Kraft.
Dann gilt als Organspender/-in,
wer sich zu Lebzeiten
nicht dagegen ausgesprochen hat.
Ein Systemwechsel, der an der Urne
angenommen worden ist.
* Friedliche Musik *
Inselspital Bern, eines
von sechs Transplantationszentren
in der Schweiz.
Hier werden Herzen und Lebern
transplantiert.
Vanessa Banz ist leitende Ärztin.
Das Spezialgebiet der Chirurgin ist,
salopp gesagt, der Bauchraum.
Sie ist Viszeral-
und Transplantationsmedizinerin.
Heute steht an, dass wir
mit einem Patienten sprechen,
der seit gut einer Woche
bei uns ist.
Er ist aktiv auf der Warteliste.
Er wartet auf ein Organ
und sein Zustand
hat sich sehr rasch verschlechtert.
Wahrscheinlich
aufgrund eines Infekts.
Er hat viel Wasser im Bauch,
ein Zeichen
einer Lebererkrankung im Endstadium.
Gestern in der Nacht haben wir
ein Angebot bekommen für ihn.
Im Idealfall
wird er heute transplantiert,
was uns natürlich wahnsinnig freut.
Morgen.
Guten Morgen, Herr Cart.
Wie geht es Ihnen heute Morgen?
Logischerweise voller Hoffnung.
Eigentlich nicht Hoffnung,
sondern die Bestätigung von dem,
was mir geschenkt wird.
Und das Wissen, dass es klappt,
dass ich noch nicht auf der Liste
fürs letzte Frühstück bin.- Mhm.
Wie war Ihre Nacht?
Panikattacke.
Ich wusste nicht, wo ich bin.
Ich brauchte etwas,
bis ich wieder wusste ...
Was spinne ich da überhaupt herum?
Aber heute Morgen haben Sie
das Gefühl, voll da zu sein?- Ja.
Wie ist das?
- Ich merke nicht viel.
Wir hatten geplant,
heute Wasser abzulassen.
Aber das werden wir
nicht jetzt noch zusätzlich machen.
Wenn offen ist, können Sie den
Wassersauger nehmen und es ist leer.
Der Infekt
ist jetzt klar kontrolliert.
Man muss sicher noch weiterfahren
mit den Antibiotika,
allenfalls mit etwas Zusätzlichem
um die Transplantation herum.
Denn am Anfang gibt es starke
Medikamente gegen die Abstossung.
Nicht,
dass der Infekt schlimmer wird.
Sobald wir hören,
dass es okay ist mit der Leber ...
Dann rufe ich meine Frau an.
- Das ist wichtig.
Nicht,
dass sie aus allen Wolken fällt,
wenn wir nach der Operation anrufen.
Dann kann man Ihnen
auch ungefähr sagen, welche Zeit.
René Cart
ist zu diesem Zeitpunkt 63 Jahre alt.
Sein Zustand
verschlechtert sich rapid.
Jetzt kommt Hoffnung auf.
Ich glaube, ich sehe Zukunftssachen,
die ich mit der Frau geplant habe,
die sich endlich erfüllen,
die wir anpacken können.
Ich freue mich einfach wahnsinnig.
Logisch, es ist ein Geschenk.
Entschuldigung,
aber es ist wirklich ein Geschenk
und ich freue mich unheimlich.
* Traurige Klänge *
Es nimmt einen schon mit.
Das sind ja nicht nur ...
Als Chirurg operiert man -
das ist sehr technisch, manuell.
Man nimmt etwas raus,
ersetzt es mit etwas.
Aber da es Patienten sind,
die lange auf der Warteliste sind,
die man immer wieder sieht,
die z.T. wiederkommen müssen,
weil sie kränker geworden sind,
baut man eine enge Beziehung
mit ihnen und der Familie auf.
René Cart
hat einen holprigen Weg vor sich.
Bei seiner Krankheit spielte früher
auch Alkohol eine Rolle.
Haben Suchtkranke
ein Anrecht auf ein Organ?
Diese Frage ist heftig umstritten.
Das Gesetz sagt:
Ja, unter gewissen Voraussetzungen.
Verantwortlich
für die Organzuteilung
ist die Stiftung Swisstransplant
im Auftrag des Bundes.
Das Computersystem errechnet,
wer ein Organ am dringlichsten
braucht, ohne Wertung.
Es kann sein,
dass man einzelne Patienten
nicht auf die Warteliste nimmt.
Es kann auch sein,
dass man bei Suchtkrankheiten
Anforderungen stellt, z.B., jemanden
nur auf die Liste zu nehmen,
wenn er nicht mehr raucht -
das ist bei der Lunge so angedacht.
Bei der Leber ist es ähnlich:
Jemand, der auf die Leberwarteliste
kommt, sollte nicht mehr trinken.
Jeder von uns
hat mal Fehler gemacht.
Wenn man die Fehler erkennt,
dazu steht,
und sagen kann:
"Fertig, jetzt ist es anders,
jetzt kehre ich mein Leben um
und trinke nicht mehr, Punkt."
"Ich habe Drogen genommen,
ich mache das nicht mehr."
"Ich habe Hepatitis C erwischt,
aber jetzt ist fertig."
Dann habe ich sehr Mühe
mit der Einstellung von Leuten,
die sagen:
"Der hat das früher aber gemacht."
"Der darf nie, der hat kein Recht
auf etwas Besseres."
* Beklemmende Klänge *
* Vogelzwitschern *
Rougemont bei Gstaad.
Bruno Romang
lebt mit einem Herzassistenten.
Die Akkus
trägt er in einer Tasche mit sich.
Seit 2004
leidet er unter Herzproblemen.
Von Jahr zu Jahr
ging es ihm schlechter.
Die Symptome
waren immer die gleichen.
Ich war sofort ausser Atem
und voll mit Wasser.
Und ich war müde.
Ich hatte keinen Appetit mehr.
Am Schluss konnte ich nur noch
eine halbe Mango gegessen.
Mehr ging nicht mehr.
Als sich sein Gesundheitszustand
verschlechtert,
bekommt er
am Universitätsspital Lausanne 2018
als Überbrückung den Herzassistenten,
auch Kunstherz genannt.
* Trübselige Klänge *
Bruno Romang
wartet auf ein Spenderorgan.
Bis zur Transplantation
braucht sein Herz Strom.
Das sind die Batterien,
relativ grosse.
Die lade ich.
So eine Batterie hält 12 Std.
Das ist der Apparat für die Nacht.
Ich habe ein Kabel
und den lasse ich immer hier.
Dann komme ich bis in die Küche,
auf die Toilette
und in mein Zimmer zum Schlafen.
Dafür habe ich sogenügend Kabel.
Wenn man schnell gehen müsste,
wenn etwas wäre,
wenn es brennen würde z.B.,
müsste ich zuerst
die Batterie anschliessen und so.
Daran denke ich ab und zu, aber
in der Regel passiert ja nichts.
Ohne Herzassistent droht der Körper
nachhaltig Schaden zu nehmen,
sodass er den Strapazen
einer Transplantation
irgendwann
nicht mehr standhalten könnte.
Bruno Romangs Fall
gilt nicht als dringlich.
Das Kunstherz an sich
gibt keine Priorisierung.
Er ist regulär auf der Warteliste.
Etwa ein Drittel der Herz-
transplantationen ist dringlich.
Zwei Drittel sind regulär.
Es ist wichtig, dass die Patienten,
die am Kunstherz sind,
eine Chance auf eine Zuteilung
eines Organs haben.
Die Wartedauer
spielt nur eine untergeordnete Rolle.
Priorität
hat die Rettung von Schwerstkranken.
D.h., dass Patienten auf der Warte-
liste oft erst ein Organ bekommen,
wenn es ihnen ganz schlecht geht.
* Trübselige Klänge *
Bruno Romang wartet.
Zurzeit sind 66 Herzpatient/-innen
auf der Warteliste.
Die durchschnittliche Wartezeit
für eine Herztransplantation
beträgt 415 Tage.
Auch Bruno Romang brauchte Geduld,
bis er ein Spenderherz bekam.
Das will gerade nicht.
Nur langsam erholt er sich
von der Transplantation.
Dass ich so stark zittere,
kommt von den Medikamenten.
Bald kann ich aufhören damit.
Dann sollte das Zittern bessern
oder verschwinden. Schau mal.
Am Anfang konnte ich
nicht mal selber unterschreiben.
Um für eine Operation zu unter-
schreiben, machte ich ein Kreuz.
Oder schrieb ganz schlecht
"Bruno Romang".
Zwei Jahre musste Bruno Romang
mit dem batteriebetriebenen Kunstherz
leben, bis er erlöst wurde.
Am Schluss wartete er
im Spital auf ein Spenderorgan.
Zu Hause ging es nicht mehr.
Ich hatte Rhythmusstörungen.
Am 2. Oktober 2020
kam ich ins Spital.
Am 7. November 2020
bekam ich das neue Herz.
Dann war ich ungefähr zwei Wochen -
vielleicht etwas mehr oder etwas
weniger, das weiss ich nicht -
im Koma.
Und dann ...
Nach dem Koma konnte ich nicht mehr
gehen, die Arme nicht mehr heben.
Auf der Halbintensivstation haben
sie mich am Abend ins Bett gelegt
und am Morgen
lag ich noch genau gleich da.
Ich konnte mich nicht mehr bewegen,
nichts.
Ich musste wieder Laufen lernen,
die Arme brauchen, um zu essen.
Die Aorta
konnten sie schlecht zusammennähen.
Die Aorta hat ausgefranst.
Dadurch
war das Blut länger draussen,
und es gab eine Infektion,
Bakterien, irgend so etwas.
Dann arbeiteten
die Nieren nicht mehr,
die Leber auch fast nicht mehr.
Dann hatte ich an der Leiste
noch eine offene Stelle.
Da gingen sie mit einem Schlauch
rauf, keine Ahnung.
Da rann die ganze Zeit
Körperflüssigkeit heraus.
Ich bekam zehn Vollnarkosen,
um das zu schliessen.
Es hielt nie.
* Traurige Musik *
Ein anderer Kollege, der dort war,
ging vier Tage nach der Operation
wieder den Gang auf und ab.
Bei ihm ging alles gut.
Bei mir ging alles nicht so gut.
Aber Bruno Romang hadert nicht.
Die vielen Medikamente
nimmt er klaglos.
Ich bin zufriedener so,
viel zufriedener.
Ich habe einfach Medikamente.
Vorher hatte ich die Maschine
und Kabel
und war abhängig vom Strom.
Jetzt bin ich frei,
ich habe ich nichts mehr.
Keinen Defibrillator,
nichts mehr - frei.
* Traurige Musik *
Bis heute,
eineinhalb Jahre nach der Operation,
kann der gelernte Zimmermann
noch keiner Arbeit nachgehen.
Ich weiss nicht, ob ich wieder
als Zimmermann arbeiten kann.
Vielleicht mache ich
etwas ganz anderes.
Als Schreiner ...
... oder sonst etwas.
Ich weiss nicht, was kommt.
Vielleicht
geht irgendwo eine Tür auf.
Ich spüre, dass es schlägt,
aber im normalen Takt.
Dass es von jemand anderem ist,
spüre ich nicht mehr.
Ich habe es aufgenommen
als Geschenk für mich.
Es passt mir sehr gut.
Es ist wie ein zweiter Geburtstag.
Wie ein zweites Leben
in diesem Fall auch fast.
* Gemütliche Klänge *
Im Inselspital ist Vanessa Banz
auf dem Weg zu René Cart,
der vor Kurzem transplantiert wurde.
Guten Tag, Herr Cart. Ça va?
- Guten Morgen. Viel besser.
Ich bin froh.
- Long time no see.
Drei Monate
sind seit dem Eingriff vergangen.
Erzählen Sie: Wie geht es Ihnen?
Wenn ich anschaue,
wie ich bis jetzt ausgesehen habe -
es sind Welten.
Aber es war auch recht schwer.
Nach der Transplantation
kam René Cart an seine Grenzen.
Höllisch.
Fast albtraummässig.
Ich stand auch zwei-, dreimal
komplett neben den Schuhen.
Sie mussten mich arretieren,
weil ich durchgestartet bin.
Ich fühlte mich wie gefangen.
Nicht existent irgendwie.
Ich wollte mich bemerkbar machen.
Das wird mir eigentlich erst jetzt
im Nachhinein richtig bewusst.
Klar, das ist schwierig.
Was mir hilft, das sage ich
den Patienten immer wieder:
"Ich weiss, es ist schwierig,
Sie stecken in dieser Situation,
können das nicht einordnen und haben
schlechte Träume - das vergeht."
Das ist der Vorteil,
wenn man häufig transplantiert:
Man sieht es immer wieder
und weiss, es ist vorübergehend.
Das kommt wieder.
Aber für den Patienten - v.a.,
wenn es darum geht, ihn anzubinden,
damit er sich nicht weh macht
oder Schläuche rausreisst,
ist es wirklich hart,
auch zum Zuschauen ist es schwierig.
Noch traut René Cart
seinem Körper nicht ganz.
Zwischendurch habe ich leichte
Schmerzen auf dieser Höhe.
Sie haben
nicht mehr so viele Muskeln,
die müssen Sie jetzt aufbauen.
Er wird sich ausgezeichnet erholen.
Heute geht es ihm gut.
So. Aber das geht schon viel besser.
- Ja, ja.
Nochmals herzlichen Dank für alles.
Es freut mich sehr, Sie so zu sehen.
- Vielen Dank.
* Verheissungsvolle Klänge *
Auch Anita Laurent
hat um ihr Leben gekämpft.
Normalität
war nicht mehr als ein Traum für sie.
Eine Spenderleber hat sie gerettet.
Genau, er hat ein gutes Profil
und ist auch für längere Strecken
gut geeignet.
Genau. Das wäre so etwas.
Oder was wir ...
Der Gleiche, einfach Wasserdicht
mit GORE-TEX.- Mhm.
Seit Kurzem arbeitet sie mit einem
40-%-Pensum in einem Laden in Scuol.
Oben kann man
mit dem Gummi regulieren.
(Lachend) Sie sehen wirklich aus
wie Langlaufschuhe.- Ja ...
Als hätte man die Socken über
die Schuhe angezogen.- Hat etwas.
Möchten Sie sie nochmals draussen
ausprobieren oder auf der Treppe?
Sie haben vorne eine super
Sprengung, damit es gut abrollt.
Und eine gute Sohle mit Grip unten.
- Ja.
Sie weiss, dass sie nicht mehr
die Gleiche ist wie früher.
Aber die Dankbarkeit überwiegt.
Es tut mir gut.
Es tut mir gut, weil ich
nicht immer nur zu Hause bin.
Ich kann meinen Kopf wieder
brauchen, was nicht so einfach ist.
Ich vergesse viel, muss wieder
nachfragen, vielleicht dreimal,
und dann
habe ich es schon wieder vergessen.
Ich vergesse wirklich viel.
Auch zu diesen Schuhen.
Ich weiss nicht mehr alles,
was zu welchem Schuh gehört.
Ich hoffe,
ich habe alles richtig erzählt.
Hinten ist er gut gedämpft
und vorne rollt er schön ab.
Ein gutes Gefühl.
Ich weiss nicht, ob es von den
Narkosen oder von der Chemo kommt.
Oder wovon auch immer.
Anita Laurent litt unter Leberkrebs.
Ihr Mann spendete ihr vor fünf Jahren
einen Teil seiner Leber.
Die Leber ist neben der Niere
das einzige Organ,
das für eine Lebendspende
in Betracht kommt.
Das war eine Option.
Unseren Kindern haben wir
versprochen, alles zu machen.
Alles, was wir machen können.
Schon jetzt aber, ein paar Tage
nach der Transplantation, ist klar:
Tschüss.
Anita Laurent muss in Kürze
noch mal operiert werden.
In ihrer Leber
ist ein Gefäss verstopft, Thrombose.
Eine gefürchtete Komplikation.
Ciao.
- Bye-bye.
Die grösste Angst
vor der Operation war,
dass ich nicht spenden kann.
Und nach der Operation,
dass sie ans Bett kommen
und sagen, die Frau sei gestorben.
Und ich hätte es nicht mitgekriegt.
Ja, das war hart.
Aber sonst hatte ich keine Angst.
Also nicht um mich -
um die Frau hatte ich grosse Angst.
Obwohl die Gefässverstopfung
rasch behoben wird,
erholt sich Anita Laurent nicht.
Zwei Monate nach der Transplantation
zeichnet sich ab:
Die Leber arbeitet nicht.
Es braucht wahnsinnig Geduld.
Ja.
* Eindringliche Hackbrettklänge *
Im letzten Jahr wurden in der Schweiz
484 Organe transplantiert.
Doch die Nachfrage
ist damit nicht gedeckt.
Insgesamt fehlen 1'500 Organe.
Vier Monate nach der Transplantation
ist Anita Laurent
immer noch im Spital.
Mittlerweile ist klar:
Die Spenderleber ihres Mannes
ist nicht zu retten.
Das war schon hart.
Jetzt bin ich auf der Warteliste
für die Transplantation,
weil es mit dieser
nicht funktioniert hat.
Und ich warte.
Denn so kann ich nicht leben.
Es ist schade,
dass es diese Komplikationen gab.
Aber es ermöglicht jetzt ...
Eine Tür geht zu
und eine andere öffnet sich.
Jetzt hat sie die Möglichkeit,
eine neue Leber zu kriegen.
Zwar diesmal von einem Totspender,
aber dafür eine ganze Leber.
Ich bin froh,
dass sie diese Chance kriegt.
Weitere drei Monate
muss Anita Laurent noch durchhalten.
Dann wird ihr zum zweiten Mal
eine Leber transplantiert -
ohne Komplikationen.
* Hoffnungsvolle Klänge *
Endlich ist Anita Laurent
zurück in Ramosch im Unterengadin,
bei ihrer Familie.
* Sie sprechen Romanisch. *
Es war lange anders.
Ja.
V.a. gleich nach der Operation
war es streng.
Nur langsam
kam Anita Laurent zu Kräften.
Erst jetzt
wagt die Familie den Rückblick -
die Eltern mit Sohn Aurelio und die
damals 13-jährigen Zwillingsmädchen.
Ich hatte eine schlechte Prognose
für den Krebs auf der Leber,
der immer am gleichen Ort
wieder wuchs.
Die einzige Möglichkeit war,
dass ich ein Stück Leber
einer anderen Person bekomme.
Mein Mann sagte sofort, er habe die
gleiche Blutgruppe, er mache das.
Ich wusste, es würde nicht einfach -
auch die Ärzte sagten,
es würde schwierig werden.
Aber ich hatte meinen Kindern
versprochen, alles zu probieren.
Aber ich sagte nie:
"Ich gehe die Leber transplantieren,
dann bin ich wieder gesund" -
das sagten wir nie.
Die Nachricht, dass der Vater
einen Teil seiner Leber spenden will,
hat die Kinder erschreckt.
Zuerst war ich nicht so begeistert.
Ich sagte Nein.
Es bestand das Risiko,
dass wir beide Eltern verlieren.
Jener Tag war sehr schlimm.
Wir sagten,
dass wir das machen wollen.
Dann sagte sie,
das wolle sie nicht -
wenn wir beide sterben,
sind sie allein.
Dann gingen wir nochmals
nach Zürich für eine Besprechung.
Der Professor kam rein
und ich sagte,
ich müsse meiner Tochter
etwas erklären.
Er sagte,
ich soll meinen Kindern sagen,
dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass ich unten überfahren werde,
grösser ist, als dass ich
nicht von der Operation zurückkomme.
Ja ... Wenn der das sagt.
Ich hatte Vertrauen in den Arzt,
dass er das irgendwie hinkriegt.
Das Beste war am Schluss,
als sie wieder heimkam,
das war wirklich schön.
Und heute? Drei Jahre später?
Anita Laurent geht es gut.
Nebst der Vergesslichkeit
plagen sie aber
fast täglich Darmbeschwerden.
Und alles geht langsamer.
Was ich früher
in einem Tag gemacht habe,
teile ich mir heute auf
in zwei bis drei Tage.
Es geht etwas länger,
aber es ist dann auch gemacht.
Meine Narben - ich hatte
viele offene Stellen am Bauch.
Jetzt ist es noch eine, die nicht zu
ist, wo ich ein Pflaster draufhabe.
Aber das stört nicht mehr so.
Man gewöhnt sich an vieles.
Das Schöne ist:
Wir gingen letztes Jahr
viel wandern und sogar klettern,
in Pontresina im Klettersteig.
Wenn wir oben in der Felswand sind,
schauen wir uns manchmal an,
und denken, noch vor Kurzem
wäre das unmöglich gewesen.
Das einzig Gute,
das wir Menschen haben, ist,
dass wir nicht wissen,
was morgen ist.- Mhm.
Wir leben jetzt.
Was morgen ist, ist morgen.
Das wissen wir zum Glück nicht.
Das ist ein grosses Geschenk.
Ja, das ist so.
Heute lebt nur noch der
zwölfjährige Aurelio ganz zu Hause.
Seine Schwestern sind in Ausbildung
und kommen nur noch
an freien Tagen heim.
* Bimmeln von Ziegenglocken *
Aurelio verbringt seine Zeit
am liebsten bei einem Bauern im Dorf.
Seit Jahren schon hilft er dort aus.
Die Erinnerungen an die schwere Zeit,
als seine Mutter krank war,
brechen auf,
wenn er darauf angesprochen wird.
Es war halt schwer für mich.
Ich wusste nicht,
ob sie noch lebt oder nicht.
Es ist halt immer die Frage ...
Wie geht es ihr?
Ist sie gut drauf?
Was sagen die Ärzte?
Immer eine Spannung.
* Er schluchzt. *
(Weinend)
Das war halt schwer für mich.
Ich wusste nie,
ob sie noch am Leben ist oder nicht.
Dann kam ich immer hier rauf.
Dann war es weg.
Dann kam ich öfter hier rauf.
* Traurige Klavierklänge *
In letzter Zeit
gab es ein paar Sachen,
die uns daran erinnert haben.
Wir merken, es ist ...
Im Alltag ist es schön versorgt.
Aber wenn etwas kommt, das uns
daran erinnert, ist es sehr präsent.
Ich glaube, auch bei den Kindern
ist es schön versorgt,
aber noch nicht verarbeitet.
Aber wir wollen das
auch nicht vorantreiben
und künstlich
mit jemandem besprechen.
Dieser Moment
kommt dann vielleicht schon.
Dann kann man es
immer noch aufräumen.
Ich hoffe,
dass es sich langsam, langsam setzt.
Aber es wird immer
eine Erinnerung sein.
* Nachdenklich stimmende
Hackbrettmelodie *
* Die Musik verklingt. *
Weisst du, was er sagt?
"Gib mir, gib mir!"
Auch Familie Rast versucht,
die Ängste hinter sich zu lassen.
Erst am Abend.
- Gibst du mir den Senf?
Er ist feiss genug.
Wir sind etwas ... easy.
Oder?
Wir versuchen es, ja.
Ich bin viel entspannter.
Vielleicht zu entspannt.
Hm, nein.
- Doch.
Aber auch bei ihnen
wird die Erinnerung bleiben.
Denn nach der Transplantation war der
Leidensweg noch lange nicht zu Ende.
Warten sind wir ja gewöhnt.
Wie denkst du, ist es für Mireya?
Eine Woche nach dem Eingriff
sind Komplikationen aufgetreten.
Nicht?
Mireya hat die Nacht
auf der Intensivstation verbracht.
Jetzt müssen wir warten,
was rauskommt.
Es ist einfach merkwürdig.
In den letzten Tagen
hat sie Fortschritte gemacht.
Jetzt ein Rückschritt.
Da fällt man selbst
auch in ein Loch.
Die neu transplantierte Leber blutet.
Die Chirurgin Barbara Wildhaber
versucht jetzt,
die Flüssigkeit
in einem Schlauch abzuleiten.
Mireyas Bauch ist stark gebläht,
sie möchte sofort operiert werden.
Ach, Maus.
Ich glaube, du möchtest in den OP,
weil du dich so unwohl fühlst.
Ja.
- Ich verstehe das.
Wir müssen effektiv
noch einmal operieren.
Sie hat geblutet in der Nacht
und Bluttransfusionen gebraucht.
Es ist noch nicht ganz still.
In diesen Situationen
muss man manchmal das Blut ausräumen
und nochmals operieren.
Es ist nicht ganz einfach.
Es ist ernst,
aber wir wissen, was machen.
Sie bereiten alles vor, Mireya.
Okay?
Stress.
- Was?- Stress.
* Er atmet laut ein und aus. *
Langsam atmen.
(Flüsternd) Nicht vergessen,
ich habe dich sehr lieb.
Hast du gehört?
- Mhm.
Ich habe dich fest gern.
Okay?
* Schwere Klavierklänge *
* Martin seufzt. *
Nach 2,5 Std. ist es überstanden.
(Ärztin) Mireya.
- (Katja) Hallo.
Hallo, Schatz.
Der Eingriff ist gut verlaufen.
Schau - hilfst du mir?
* Hoffnungsvolle Musik *
Nur langsam, langsam.
Geht es nicht mehr? Müde?
- Mami hält dich.
Steh hinter sie, sie wackelt.
- Ja, mache ich.
Einen Monat nach der Transplantation
wartet Familie Rast auf den Bescheid
der Ärztinnen und Ärzte.
Alle drei möchten endlich nach Hause.
Es war heftig.
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass es so heftig wird.
Was?
Die Zeit, seit sie angerufen haben
bis jetzt.
Das war eine Horrorzeit.
Wenn du von deinem Kind
die Worte hörst,
dass sie sterben will
und solche Sachen.
Für mich war das schlimmer
als die Operation.
Eines Tages
verweigerte Mireya die Medikamente.
Sie mussten ihr zweimal mit einer
Ernährungssonde verabreicht werden.
Auch heute gibt es einen Rückschlag.
Mireyas Bauch ist wieder geschwollen.
Hallo. Schlechte Nachricht?
Ein bisschen. Es ist nicht möglich,
heute nach Hause zu gehen.
Fast gedacht.
- (Mireya) Morgen?
Ob morgen, das weiss ich nicht.
Sie hat
etwas Flüssigkeit in der Lunge.
Das ist nicht gut.
Heute machen wir die Punktion
für die Flüssigkeit.
(Weinerlich)
Ich habe aber schon so viel erlebt.
Wenn der Arzt das sagt,
was willst du machen?
Mireya, du siehst selbst,
dass dein Bauch gross ist.
Ich will einfach mal heim.
Mireya weiss, was es heisst, wenn
Gewebeflüssigkeit entnommen wird.
Bei schlechtem Bescheid,
wenn Fett in der Flüssigkeit ist,
arbeitet die Leber
noch nicht richtig.
Lachgas
soll ihr durch den Eingriff helfen.
Nicht bewegen. Voilà.
Ich halte die Hände.
Mireya, das ist wichtig.
(Weinerlich)
Das tut aber Millionen weh.
Aufhören.
Jetzt heisst es warten -
auf die Laborergebnisse.
Wir haben gute Nachrichten.
- Also, raus damit.
Zuletzt hatte es ja
zu viel Fett in der Flüssigkeit.
Das hat es jetzt nicht mehr.
Das ist gut.
(Katja) Also kein Fett drin?
Wir haben gedacht, dass ihr übers
Wochenende in den Urlaub könntet,
und wir uns am Montag wiedersehen
für eine Kontrolle.
Aber Papi,
das ist eine ganz gute Nachricht.
Wir können ... Mami,
wir können selber Essen machen.
Aber ohne Fett.
Mireya darf das Wochenende
in der Wohnung verbringen,
die das Spital den Eltern
günstig zur Verfügung stellt.
Bist du entspannt?
- Mhm. Sehr.
Gut.
Musst du einen Sirup nicht
in den Kühlschrank tun?- Nein.
Sie hat nicht mehr die,
die in den Kühlschrank müssen.
Pass auf mit dem Glas.
- Ah, das ist die ...
Das ist die ...
Riecht wie Jägermeister.
Eins, zwei.
Mami.
Bravo.
Alles gut?
Irgendwie merkwürdig,
ohne Schläuche.
(Navi-Stimme)
Die Route wird berechnet.
Nur Tage später geht es
ganz nach Hause, nach Emmenbrücke.
Wir gehen heim, heim, heim, heim.
Zu Hause ist es immer am schönsten.
Rocco.
Kennst du sie noch?
Das ist Mireya.
Beruhige dich, Rocco.
Unsere Familie ist wieder zusammen.
* Friedliche Klänge *
* Trübselige Klänge *
Mireya lebt dank einer Organspende.
Jedes Jahr sterben in der Schweiz
aber Dutzende von Menschen,
die vergeblich warten.
Ob Ja oder Nein:
Ein klarer Entscheid zur Organspende
entlastet die Angehörigen
und das medizinische Personal.
"Es tut mir leid, dass ich nicht
immer dieses starke Vorbild bin,
für das mich viele hier halten."
"Manchmal - ja, da habe ich
ganz gehörig die Schnauze voll."
"Momente, in denen ich
aus meinem Körper ausbrechen
und ganz weit wegrennen möchte
und vielleicht einfach auch einmal
ein bisschen normal sein will."
Eliane Gutzwiller leidet an der
Lungenkrankheit Cystische Fibrose.
Sie brauchte eine Spenderlunge.
Die Transplantation
liegt Jahre zurück.
Damals hatte sie
mit dem Leben schon abgeschlossen.
Das Spenderorgan
kam im letzten Moment.
All die Erlebnisse
teilt sie mit ihren Followern.
Ein Hauptthema ist das Leben
mit einer transplantierten Lunge.
Das ist das grobe Thema.
Dann die Spitalaufenthalte.
Die Therapie,
die ich im Moment machen muss.
Wenn ich wieder
psychische Probleme habe,
versuche ich, den Leuten
zu erklären, wie das ist.
Und es hilft mir hauptsächlich,
das Ganze zu verarbeiten.
"Against normal", "Gegen die
Normalität", heisst Elianes Blog.
Es geht um Kleider, Frisuren,
Rezepte und Krankheit.
Ich habe gemerkt,
dass ich Menschen Mut machen kann,
die selbst etwas haben.
Ich möchte anderen,
die dasselbe wie ich haben,
die noch nicht transplantiert sind,
Kraft schenken und ihnen zeigen,
dass man nicht nur die Krankheit
ist, sondern auch eine Person.
Eliane Gutzwiller lebt allein.
Für den Beruf fehlen
der gelernten Kauffrau die Kräfte.
Ich arbeite seit Längerem
an einem Kinderbuch.
Ich schreibe sehr gerne.
Seit einem Jahr habe ich
das Zeichnen für mich entdeckt.
Wenn ich mal nicht mehr da bin,
möchte ich etwas hinterlassen.
Eine eigene Familie
wird sie nicht gründen können.
Die Krankheit
bestimmt die Lebensplanung.
Ich habe mit dem Gedanken
schon früh abgeschlossen,
je eigene Kinder zu bekommen.
Mit 18 wurde mir gesagt, es sei
nicht schlau, Kinder zu bekommen.
Das würde mein Körper
gar nicht schaffen.
Ich wäre neun Monate im Spital.
Und es wäre fraglich,
ob ich die Geburt überleben würde.
Eliane Gutzwiller
möchte leben wie alle anderen auch.
Aber der Körper macht ihr
einen Strich durch die Rechnung.
Er will die transplantierte Lunge
nicht mehr akzeptieren.
Seit Februar
habe ich eine chronische Abstossung.
Deshalb gehe ich
in eine sog. Lichttherapie,
wo die weissen Blutkörperchen
so verändert werden,
dass sie nicht mehr
gegen die Lunge wirken.
Das dauert immer zwei Tage.
Dafür packe ich mein Köfferchen,
also den Rucksack.
Chronische Abstossung.
Ein Schock, aber kein Todesurteil,
sagt Eliane.
Man kann nicht sagen, wie lange man
mit der Abstossung lebt.
Aber das kann man sonst auch nicht.
Ich könnte unter den Bus kommen,
und dann ist es auch vorbei.
(Durchsage)
Nächster Halt, Zürich Hauptbahnhof.
Die Diagnose
hat Eliane Gutzwiller zurückgeworfen.
Aber: Die neue Therapie hält
die chronische Abstossung in Schach.
Photopherese heisst die Behandlung,
eine Art Blutwäsche.
Die weissen Blutzellen
werden ausserhalb des Körpers
mit einer Substanz versetzt
und mit UV-A-Licht bestrahlt.
Dafür braucht Eliane einen sog. Port,
ein Kathetersystem unter der Haut.
Der wurde gemacht, weil ich relativ
schlechte Venen an den Armen habe.
Bei diesen Therapien
müssen die Venen stabiler sein.
Die Gefahr, dass meine Venen
platzen, ist relativ gross.
Deshalb hat man den Port gelegt.
Eliane hat dem Port
einen Namen gegeben: Jason Justin.
Ich konnte viel besser
damit umgehen.
Mit dem Fremdkörper,
den ich hier habe.
Irgendwie konnte ich es mit Humor
nehmen, als er einen Namen hatte.
Die Photopherese
kann die chronische Abstossung
nicht zum Verschwinden bringen,
aber immerhin bremsen.
Es gibt mir Hoffnung, dass die
Lungenfunktion nicht weiter sinkt.
Eine Garantie hat man nie.
* Ruhige Musik *
Eliane ist zuversichtlich,
bis zum heutigen Tag.
Es geht mir immer noch gleich.
Ich hatte aber letzten August,
also 2021,
noch mal einen Schub
von der Abstossung.
Ich verlor etwas Lungenvolumen.
Das hat mich anfangs eingeschränkt.
Jetzt beeinträchtigt es mich
nicht mehr gross,
weil sich der Körper
relativ gut daran gewöhnt hat.
Im Frühling aber
musste die 28-Jährige
innerhalb von nur zwei Monaten
gleich dreimal ins Spital.
Zuerst wegen schlechter Nierenwerte.
Es folgte eine Infektion.
Die Bakterien befielen auch den Port.
Jason Justin wurde entfernt.
Eliane wollte raus aus dem Spital.
Und sehnte sich nach ihrem Emil.
Er ist mein Ein und Alles.
Nicht wahr? Ja.
Hm?
Nicht in die Infusion beissen.
Vielen Dank.
Er gibt mir einen Alltag.
Eine Routine.
Und ...
Eigentlich bestimmt er mein Leben.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Mit psychischen Problemen,
einer Depression
und Panik ist es nicht so einfach.
Er hilft mir sehr, nicht wahr?
Komm! Bring das Äffchen.
(Lachend) Selber holen.
Jeder Spitalaufenthalt
ruft bei Eliane
die Erinnerung an die lange Wartezeit
vor dem grossen Eingriff wach.
Als sie kaum mehr Luft bekam
und fast verzweifelte.
Ich bekomme vielfach Angst,
dass ich nicht mehr rauskomme.
Nicht mehr aus dem Spital
entlassen werde.
Das war Thema
vor der Transplantation.
"Sie können erst nach Hause,
wenn Ihre neue Lunge da ist."
Das bringt mich
in eine Stresssituation.
Oder wenn ich nachts
nicht schlafen kann.
Das ist im Spital
auch ganz unangenehm.
Das sind solche Beispiele.
* Ruhige Musik *
Komm!
Bring es! Komm!
Als Hobby
gehe ich mit ihm ins Trickdog.
Dort lernt er z.B. ...
Dreh.
Und sitz.
Und Männchen.
Und Platz.
Seite.
Ich habe ... Ja!
* Schnalzen *
Super.
Solche Sachen.
Gehen wir raus?
* Ruhige Musik *
Ich nehme jeden Tag, wie er kommt.
Ich versuche,
das Beste daraus zu machen.
Ich möchte auch keine Perspektive.
Niemand soll mir sagen, was
für eine Lebenserwartung ich habe.
Das kann man bei einem gesunden
Menschen auch nicht sagen.
Auf der Intensivstation
des Inselspitals
ist eine Patientin gestorben.
Nebenan, in einem Besprechungsraum,
wartet der Ehemann.
Sie hatte einen Reitunfall.
Sie ist gestürzt und mit dem Kopf
auf einen Baum aufgeschlagen.
Die Verletzungen waren harmlos, aber
sie hat das Bewusstsein verloren.
Sie ist dann am Erbrochenen
nicht erstickt,
aber sie bekam keine Luft mehr,
es kam zum Herzstillstand.
Sie konnte reanimiert werden.
Aber die Schäden im Hirn
waren zu gross,
sodass sie nach zwei Tagen
im Inselspital verstorben ist.
Die Ärzte haben mit der Familie
gesprochen, und es steht fest:
Die Frau ist Organspenderin.
Sie wird deshalb weiterhin beatmet.
Jetzt wird der Hirntod
offiziell festgestellt.
Die Frau ist tiefkomatös,
ohne Narkosemedikamente.
Es geht darum, nachzuweisen, dass
die Hirnstammreflexe erloschen sind.
Dass keine Funktion des Hirns
mehr da ist.
Damit will man beweisen,
dass die Durchblutung des Hirns
ausgefallen ist.
Die Ärzte prüfen, ob sich das Auge
der Patientin schliesst,
wenn es mit einem Wattestäbchen
berührt wird.
Ich sehe keine Reaktion.
- Das ist gut.
Ich auch nicht.
Mathias Nebiker
drückt auf gewisse Schmerzpunkte.
Keine Reaktion.
Ich sehe nichts.
Und er testet, ob sich der Kopf
reflexartig zurückdreht,
wie das bei einem Schlafenden
der Fall wäre.
Ich sehe keine Bewegung.
- Nein. Ich auch nicht.
Mit einem kleinen Schlauch
wird der Rachen berührt.
Normalerweise würde jemand husten.
Der Reflex bleibt auch hier aus.
Der Ablauf der Hirntoddiagnostik
ist streng geregelt.
Zwei unabhängige Ärzte, ein
Intensivmediziner und eine Neurologin
müssen das Prozedere
gemeinsam durchführen.
Schliesslich wird der Beatmungstubus
1 Min. lang entfernt,
um zu klären, ob die Patientin
selbstständig atmen würde.
Ich sehe keine Bewegungen.
- Ich auch nicht.
Ich mache ihn wieder dran.
Alle Hirnstammreflexe
sind erloschen.
Die Patientin atmet nicht.
Beide Ärzte
unterschreiben das Protokoll.
Das ist der Todeszeitpunkt.
* Schwere Klänge *
Dank der Beatmung sieht es aus,
als würde die Frau einfach schlafen.
Kritiker der Organtransplantation
stellen infrage,
ob eine hirntote Person
wirklich nichts mehr spürt.
Den Organspendern werde
ein würdevolles Sterben verwehrt.
Es ist unbestritten,
dass nicht jede Körperzelle
die Funktion verloren hat.
Was klar ist:
Die Hirnfunktion ist erloschen.
Das Hirn ist nicht mehr durchblutet.
Das Hirn macht uns aus.
Hirntote Patienten
erwachen nie mehr.
In Schock und Trauer
sehen sich die Angehörigen
mit der Frage
nach einer Organspende konfrontiert.
Das ist sicher im Sinne
meiner verstorbenen Frau,
weil sie im medizinischen,
tiermedizinischen Bereich tätig war.
Wir beide, meine Tochter und ich,
haben das Gefühl,
dass wir im Sinne meiner Frau Ulla
entschieden haben.
Jetzt laufen die Vorbereitungen
für die Organentnahme.
Es braucht Blutuntersuchungen
und Gewebetypisierungen,
um herauszufinden,
zu wem die Organe am besten passen.
Die Empfängerzentren
wollen sicher sein,
dass sie
voll funktionsfähige Organe bekommen
und keine Krankheit
unentdeckt bleibt.
Frau Wehrle, wir drehen Sie jetzt
auf die linke Seite.
Nicht erschrecken.
Die Kollegin wird sich
die Haut noch mal anschauen.
Es fällt auf: Die Pflegefachfrau
erklärt jeden Schritt,
obwohl die Patientin verstorben ist.
Dann legen wir Sie zurück
auf den Rücken. Nicht erschrecken.
Okay.
Das hat für mich
mit respektvoller Betreuung zu tun.
Sie ist für mich nach wie vor
ein Mensch mit einer Seele.
Absolut.
Die verstorbene Patientin
wird zugunsten der Organempfänger
gepflegt und gewärmt.
Wer die Organe bekommt, ist bestimmt.
Jetzt geht es in den Operationssaal.
Zur Organentnahme.
Wie lange bleibt die Seele im Körper?
Gibt es sie überhaupt?
Wird der Sterbeprozess
durch die Organentnahme gestört?
Auch wenn medizinisch alles klar ist,
für viele bleiben Fragen offen.
Für diesen Film haben wir
verschiedene Organentnahmen gedreht
und die Bilder zusammengefügt.
Das dient der Anonymisierung und
damit der Entlastung der Angehörigen,
die alle ihr Einverständnis
für die Dreharbeiten gegeben haben.
Die Chirurgin Vanessa Banz macht sich
auf den Weg zur Organentnahme,
nach einem vollen Arbeitstag.
Jemand ist gestorben.
Das belastet viel mehr,
als wenn man weiss,
da ist jemand, der lebt,
und man eine Operation machen darf.
Man muss extrem vorsichtig arbeiten.
Ein Organ ist sehr rar.
Eine Verletzung könnte dazu führen,
dass das Organ
nicht transplantierbar wäre.
Eigentlich ist es eine Operation
wie jede andere auch.
Aber für einmal nicht
zugunsten des Operierten,
sondern der Organempfänger.
Zwei Leben berühren sich.
Die Kosten der Entnahme trägt
die Krankenkasse des Organempfängers.
Insgesamt kommt eine Transplantation
auf 100'000-250'000 Fr. zu stehen.
Das Freilegen der Organe
dauert Stunden.
Merci.
Endlich
kann die Leber entnommen werden.
Könnte ich die feine Schere haben?
Sie wird sofort gespült, damit
verbleibendes Blut nicht gerinnt.
Das ist wirklich eine schöne Leber.
Die Leute fragen immer,
bis wann sie spenden können.
Es gibt Leute, die mit 50 eine Leber
haben, die nicht mehr optimal ist.
Und dann gibt es Leute, die mit 86
eine wunderschöne Leber haben,
zu der gut geschaut wurde.
Die könnte man sofort nehmen.
* Monotone Klänge *
Das ist die rechte Niere.
Danke schön. Niere rechts.
- Ja, Niere rechts.
Die gekühlten Organe können Stunden
ausserhalb des Körpers bleiben.
Die kostbare Fracht wird in diesem
Fall auf der Strasse transportiert -
von einem spezialisierten
Transportunternehmen.
Der Körper des Organspenders ist
inzwischen wieder zugenäht worden.
Das ist meine Art,
Abschied zu nehmen.
Noch mal an die Schulter fassen.
Wenn ich in die Intensivstation
komme, trete ich auch so in Kontakt.
Eine kurze Berührung. Ich
merke mir das Gesicht des Menschen.
Im Aufbahrungsraum werden sich auch
die Angehörigen verabschieden können.
* Schwere Klänge *
Rapperswil am Zürichsee.
Christian Reutemann
wartet auf eine Spenderlunge.
Das ist
mein mobiles Sauerstoffgerät.
Jetzt gehe ich die Post holen.
Da sind dabei:
mein Telefon
und mein Notfallspray.
Reutemann
leidet seit zehn Jahren an COPD,
einer chronisch obstruktiven
Lungenkrankheit.
Bewegung wird zur Qual.
Das ist Station 1.
Hier mache ich immer
eine kurze Pause.
Rund um die Uhr ist er
auf das Sauerstoffgerät angewiesen.
Ganz am Anfang
habe ich mich gefragt: "Warum ich?"
Diese Frage
kann man nicht beantworten.
Sie führt nirgendwohin.
Ich war auch wütend ...
... als ich gemerkt habe,
dass ich etwas nicht mehr schaffe.
Aber das bringt genauso wenig.
Man muss versuchen,
nach vorne zu schauen,
das Positive zu sehen.
Wobei es bei dieser Krankheit
eigentlich nur eine Prognose gibt.
COPD ist unheilbar.
Christian Reutemanns Ehe
ist vor zwei Jahren zerbrochen.
Seine Ex-Frau ist aber immer noch
Tag und Nacht da für ihn,
wenn er in Atemnot gerät.
* Anschwellende, bedrückende Klänge *
Die Arbeit als leitender Angestellter
in der IT von Tchibo
musste er aufgeben.
Die Wohnung verlässt er kaum mehr.
Früher spielte Christian Reutemann
Tuba.
U.a. auch
bei der Stadtmusik Rapperswil.
Er habe wild gelebt,
geraucht und gekifft.
Dazu steht er.
Was wäre gewesen,
wenn ich nicht geraucht hätte?
Diese Gedanken habe ich mir gemacht.
Aber daran denkt man mit 20 nicht -
ich zumindest nicht.
Da gibt's aber nur einen.
- (Mann) Holen wir uns noch einen.
Jetzt machst du auch schon
einen auf Shopping-Queen?
Nein, leihen, mieten.
Alle Felder sind erntereif.
Nur in der virtuellen Welt
hat Christian Reutemann Raum.
Er spielt oft im Team
mit Achim aus Berlin,
der vom Gamer-Kumpel
zum Freund geworden ist.
Das muss gesät werden.
Wusste ich es doch.
Das ist noch nicht gemacht worden.
- Achim. Jetzt hörst du mich?
Jetzt höre ich dich.
Ich habe vergessen, den Kopfhörer
anzuschalten.- Kann passieren.
Mir geht's gut. Dir?
- Kann nicht klagen.
Heute geht es mir wieder gut.
- Dann ist ja gut.
Rund 5 Std. pro Tag verbringt
Christian Reutemann mit Gamen,
oft zusammen mit Achim.
Ich sehe sofort, wie es Chris geht.
Ich höre es an der Stimme.
Ich sehe es,
wenn wir uns über Video sehen.
Ich sehe, wie es Chris geht.
Einmal bin ich sofort
zu ihm geflogen,
als ich gemerkt habe,
dass es ihm nicht gut geht.
Ich habe auch
Probleme mit der Lunge.
Ich kann das etwas nachfühlen.
Und ... das passt.
Ich drücke ihm alle Daumen,
dass es gut wird.
Schnell fahren, Chris.
- Danke für den Hinweis.
Oh. So.
Alle Felder sind abgeerntet.
Früher war eine Modelleisenbahn das
grosse Hobby von Christian Reutemann.
Zurzeit aber steht alles still.
Nach der Transplantation gibt es
unten durch einen Schattenbahnhof.
Da werden alle Züge abgestellt.
Dann kommen sie auf diese Etage.
Da gibt es einen grossen Kreis,
wo der Bahnhof sein wird.
Ich denke, in dieser Region hier
gibt es eine schöne Fahrstrecke.
Das ist ein Ziel dieser Operation.
Aber hier bauen, machen -
das schaffe ich jetzt nicht.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Ja.
Am Tag, an dem Ende 2019 am Fernsehen
seine Geschichte erzählt wird,
bekommt Christian Reutemann
ein neues Organ.
Den Film schaut er sich im Spital an,
kurz bevor er
in den Operationssaal geschoben wird.
Reutemann ist zurück - noch nicht
im Beruf, aber in seinem Hobby.
Es ist so geworden, wie ich es mir
damals vorgestellt habe
und wie ich es
2019 beschrieben habe.
Seither
bin ich voll und ganz zufrieden.
Ich freue mich auch.
Jetzt habe ich
vollautomatischen Betrieb.
Im Moment ist der Zufallsgenerator
drin. Ich muss nichts machen.
Es sind drei Züge,
die autonom fahren.
Das ist wohl der Traum jedes Buben.
Es raucht ein wenig.
Der müsste noch mehr Pep haben.
Reutemann hat angefangen,
gewisse Bauteile für die Eisenbahn
selber zu entwerfen
und dreidimensional auszudrucken.
Er steckt aber auch
in einem Arbeitsintegrationsprogramm,
um in seinen Beruf als IT-Spezialist
zurückkehren zu können.
Morgen.
- Grüezi.
Man muss
sehr konzentriert dabei sein.
Eine falsche Medikation
kann unangenehme Folgen haben.
Man muss beachten:
Ein Leben mit Spenderorgan heisst,
dass das Immunsystem
lebenslang unterdrückt wird,
damit keine Abstossung stattfindet.
Donnerstag, Freitag,
Samstag, Sonntag, Montag.
Ab in die Box damit.
Was es heisst, mit einem
unterdrückten Immunsystem zu leben,
lernt jeder Organempfänger
und jede Organempfängerin
schon vor der Transplantation.
* Ruhige Musik *
Ich habe z.B. die Empfehlung
vom Unispital bekommen,
dass ich nur schon einen Schnitt
in den Finger melden soll,
da daraus Komplikationen
entstehen könnten.
Als ich mal
hier auf dem Weg spazieren ging,
hatte ich nach einer
längeren Strecke offene Fersen.
In der Verlaufskontrolle
sagten sie mir,
ich hätte
einen erhöhten Entzündungswert.
Sie fragten,
warum ich das nicht gemeldet hätte.
Es könnten sich
Bakterien einschleichen.
Und das könnte zu
einer schlimmen Entzündung führen.
Wie gesagt: Mein Immunsystem
ist heruntergefahren.
Da ist die Möglichkeit
für eine Infektion
viel grösser
als bei einem gesunden Menschen.
Trotz der Einschränkung -
Christian Reutemann lebt in Frieden.
Wenn mich die Leute fragen, wie ich
mit einem fremden Organ leben könne,
sage ich, mein Organspender müsse
eine sehr gute Person gewesen sein.
So wie sich die Lunge an mich
und meinen Körper angepasst hat.
Ich hatte ja auch
sehr wenige Komplikationen.
Ich denke,
besser hätte es nicht gehen können.
Es muss
ein guter Mensch gewesen sein.
* Ruhige Musik *
Seit Jahren bemüht sich der Bund,
die Spendebereitschaft
der Schweizerinnen und Schweizer
zu erhöhen.
Erst in ein paar Jahren
wird sich zeigen,
ob die neue Widerspruchslösung
dazu beiträgt.
Wenn alle sich mit der Organspende
auseinandersetzen,
mit der Endlichkeit,
mit der Zukunft.
Ich habe keine Zukunftsängste.
Also für Mireya? Nein.
Die Medizin wird fortschrittlicher.
Vielleicht gibt es neue Medikamente
oder Behandlungsmethoden.
Das könnte sich verlängern.
Vielleicht kann sie 20 Jahre oder
sogar mehr leben. Ich weiss nicht.
Es kommt auf den Organismus an.
Wovor hast du Angst, Mireya?
- Vor nichts.
Auch vor nichts.
- Ja.
Einfach das Leben geniessen.
(Aus dem Off) Ich habe keine Angst.
Angst vor dem Sterben
habe ich schon lange nicht mehr.
Ich sage immer: Ich entscheide
nicht, wann ich gehen muss.
Mit dem neuen Herz
will ich schon schauen,
dass ich es gut behandle.
Ich möchte mein Bestes geben.
Es ist ein gutes, liebes Herz.
Es hat verdient,
dass ich gut zu ihm schaue.
Ich sage es immer:
Es ist mein Leben.
Das gehört einfach dazu.
Klar, ich habe es mir
nicht so ausgesucht.
Aber es macht mich zu dem,
was ich bin.
Das Leben kann sehr schön sein.
Ich darf es wieder erleben.
Und ...
Das möchte ich so lange wie möglich
nicht aus der Hand geben.
* Ruhige, ergreifende Musik *
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Martina Riedi, Daniela Zacheo